[Music]
hastings left salt lake city
attracted his movements all the way to
cuba we have to assume percy is moving
nuke there
langley believes castro could help
perseus smuggle it into the us
in exchange for a peek at the hardware
of course that isn't gonna happen
what's the plan the last read we have on
hastings came from 30 miles south of
havana we suspect perseus is using an
abandoned compound there to hold the
nuke
they're working under the radar so
expect moderate security
i say we smash and grab parachute in
grab nuke
skyhook and what if the nuke isn't there
it's there the only reason perseus needs
hastings in cuba is to prepare it for
arming and detonation
there you have it that's an old range rx
fill while we're in route
if everyone's ready let's move out
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
where early adler should be checking in
right about
we're in position copy that we're moving
to flank
all teams
do the honor spell
moving on
freelancing
lay down
[Music]
watching smoke
oh
wow
oh
a moment
what did these poor bastards do they
finished their job they love a reward
they've got close circuit cameras we
could use them to locate the nuclear
bomb
sharp as ever
[Music]
what did these poor bastards do they
finished their job
they've got close circuit cameras we
could use them to locate the nuclear
bomb
sharp as ever
contact
[ __ ] is everyone all right
ambush
[Music]
rpg on the balcony
[Music]
uh
what do you say we finally got that
mason you missed one behind the counter
keep looking there hold it adler we have
eyes on
second floor room 27b
second floor center room upstairs let's
move
crude but effective okay keep your eyes
out of me
bell use the c4
we're moving to the second floor move
ahead we'll catch up
yoda
i'm moving
please
i'm looking
forward
please they're shooting at us stay away
oh
i'm looking
[Music]
please
right
cover me
they're really hot
moving on
down
hastings stop talking perseus
was here he shot us
escaped perseus would never leave his
precious nuke behind
he forced us to reverse engineer the
detonation codes
they gave him full access to greenlight
what
are you telling me perseus can detonate
multiple nukes in europe
i'm so sorry hastings
stay with us how many green light
devices can perseus detonate with those
codes
he can detonate all of them
he'll wipe out half of europe and blame
it all on the usa
we need to find that son of a [ __ ]
perseus
time to go no contact chopper coming in
low
it's gotta be perseus head to the roof
[Music]
he's climbing into
go
remember to keep your backs to the wind
inbound in two
you got snipers on the minutes
think i'm ready for that drink now don't
tease me park
but we'll have none of that horse piss
get ready here they come
great
[Music]
[Music]
now that's something worth fighting this
is hot as hell can we lend an assist
that would be much appreciated
bullseye
probably that skyhawk i could see the
plane park we need to hook into the line
now
we'll do it in turns bell you harness up
first we'll cover
[Music]
go
take cover [ __ ]
reach
[Music]
well that was a goddamn fiasco you go in
with the intel you have
not the intel you want we paid the
[ __ ] piper down there
you think this is belt's fault i don't
know whose fault it is
i just know that perseus doesn't have a
single [ __ ] nuke
he's got dozens millions of people are
gonna die
and the united states will take the
blame you
need to find out where he's planning to
broadcast the activation signal
are we gonna pull that out of our ass
bell knows where it is
well this goddamn science project was a
failure
don't count eller out yet the man has a
deep bag of tricks
come on a little further
get the gurney
bell i feel like i owe you
[Music]
bloody hell
[Music]
i'm going to lose a lot more than lazar
if we don't execute this next move
correctly
we need you to hang in there for one
more assignment
counting on you again bell sims
get the dosages ready all of them
adler stop wasting our valuable time
he's of no use to us anymore
stay alert though you're the key to
stopping persons
you always have
no more half-fasting we're doing an
intracerebral injection
injecting directly into the brain could
provoke seizures or worse
damn do the eye socket you sure about
this doc
memory should begin almost immediately
bell listen to me i need you to remember
think back to our time in vietnam one
more time
we need to finish what we started
we had a job to do
think bell perseus do you remember
coming face to face with perseus in
vietnam
ekg is spiking
[ __ ] heart rate's off the charts i need
you to relax
and focus bell your helicopter crashed
you made your way through the jungle
alone you found a bunker
you remember the bunker bell we need to
know what's inside that bunker
is lying to you do not trust him
do not listen to ever he is lying
to you he is
during a mission to investigate reports
of a soviet bunker
your chopper was hit by ground fire
to your debrief you woke up in the
middle of a firefight
the crash survivors were defending
against a vc attack
you ran forward and picked up an m16
or maybe it was another one
ah
oh
enemies
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hey
the remaining vc fled into the tree line
it was then you realized you were the
sole survivor
you set off to locate the bunker
the path split near a ruin so he took
the right fork
not the trail to the left
come back here i'm not done talking to
you
you heard russian voices from a cave
across the river so you went to
investigate
bell i need you to turn around and go
into the cave
the zip line nearby was the best way
back to the cave
he wanted to get to that bunker as soon
as possible
you equipped your shotgun and had a boat
that's when you discovered vc soldiers
meeting with soviet agents
good
ah
thank you
here
when we got boy
uh
yes bill that was the door into the
soviet bunker
yes good the bunker now tell me about
perseus
ah we almost had it let's run six okay
ready bell we've got a job to do
according to your debrief you woke up
and the rest of your crew
was missing the vc were on the ground
searching for survivors
you ready your bow to take them out
silently
[Music]
wow
oh my god
the path split near a ruin so you took
the well-traveled trail on your left
not toward the waterfall on the right
you mentioned crossing a bridge the
bucket is somewhere on the other side
at the fork you followed the road right
toward the sound of gunfire
seeing a firefight you readied your m16
you stirred up a hornet's nest
a
what's up
red team change your hostile
yes this was the bunker entrance you
described in the report
[Music]
this could be the onset of another focal
seizure
no don't stop bill [ __ ] [ __ ]
hand me the fallback scenario manual
here it is
bell we've got a job to do
[Music]
according to your debrief you woke up in
the middle of a firefight
crash survivors were defending against
the dc attack
he was ready to grenade launcher and
charged
[Music]
well i need to know about the bunker
start again
ready to grenade launcher in charge
so
you just ran away that doesn't sound
like you
[Music]
the path split near a ruin so you took
the well-traveled trail on your left
not toward the waterfall on the right
[Music]
reports had the [ __ ] across the bridge
you went left at the fork not right
few allies were pinned down on a ridge
you readied your sniper rifle to assist
30 seconds out
roger here we go
[Music]
inside the house hit by napalm you'd
find a hidden bunker door
go check it out
i don't care if the door was [ __ ]
stuck open it
park give bell another injection
do it now
heart rate is spiking i'm not sure how
much longer bell can last
heart rate is coming down now
now
bell stop speaking circles
stop wasting my time with this hallway
turn around
what the hell is bill doing in the lab
bell forget about the damn lamp i need
to know about the bunker
congrats the united states and its
allies
slowly consumed
shut up
we've known each other for years it
appears
[Music]
script 17 ready
bell we've got a job to do
we've been over this already
skip ahead to the next party
the bunker door was right there at the
ruins bell
you went in
bell go into the bunker now
you're the only one who knows where
perseus is where he'll detonate the
nukes
[Music]
the united states and its allies slowly
consume
that which is dear to us our leaders
continue to weaken under this threat
it is the moral duty of perseus to act
when they will not
soon we will possess an american nuclear
bomb
the key to unlocking their entire green
light arsenal
once we control the green light arsenal
we will detonate them
all from the safety of zolowski
you gotta admit i'm
i surprised think they'd recover so fast
we tried
everything normal forms of interrogation
won't work
breaking a subject's will and erasing
their mind is a difficult and painful
process
that's a small price to pay the cia's
mind control program has had a great
deal of success with implanted memories
you want me to tell them about my time
in vietnam lastly
you'll need a command phrase to trigger
the implanted memories
we have a job
[Music]
we've got a job to do and now the
training is complete
you just need to give the subject a name
[Music]
bell
perseus the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world you've
been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
the united states and its allies slowly
consume
that which is dear to us we are hours
away from perseus detonating nuclear
bombs in every major european city
we'll do whatever it takes
some of us across the line to make sure
the line's still there in the morning
no one's gonna brand us heroes or
villains
they don't know us as for me
i've been chasing this ghost for 13
years
that ends now
bell we gotta go now
they did it mr president they stopped
the nukes
thank did they get perseus
no sir his whereabouts are unknown and a
russian response
nothing yet we're seeing signs of
confusion
it's possible this was all a rogue
operation
perseus may not have been following
orders from moscow
well i'll be damned maybe we have
something in common
after all
we stopped him those towers are history
what's your situation down there
come in woods have you found them yet
over here give me a hand
take my hand bell
we did it this is a message to perseus
and those that'll follow him
we don't just sit back and hope for the
best
we'll make the best happen this is how
wars are won belle
do you have an update on kasim javadi
yeah
after capturing kasim javadi we've
convinced him he's better off working
for us
rather than against us the death of
arash kadivar opens a path for kasim to
take control of their network
he'll give us deeper insight into soviet
activity in the middle east
and with our resources behind him he
should be able to influence regional
affairs for years to come
what about anton volkov volkov has
become a prime source of information
since his capture
after interrogating him mi6 quickly
established a series of listening posts
in east berlin
they've already intercepted messages
from the kgb to assets throughout the
city
we're poking holes in the iron curtain
how did the cleanup in havana go we were
able to recover agent azole's body from
the compound in cuba
president reagan personally reached out
to his family in his caskets in transit
to tel aviv
as you know helen park returned to
london she'll continue to recover from
her injuries there
afterwards mi6 plans to give her a task
force dedicated to finding perseus
what about the rest of the team they got
off soloveski before the soviets could
send in forces to investigate
we'll take some time to heal up that
it's back to work
we may have stopped perseus but his rats
are still nesting all around us
thanks to the help of one of our own
not anymore we took down that son of a
[ __ ] aldrich
as well as his key assets here in the
states it'll take perseus a while to
recover from this one
what about europe not only did we stop a
nuclear attack
we managed to take out major vadim
rudnik that should be a significant blow
to perseus's european network we also
flushed all of ridnik's key assets down
the [ __ ]
maybe someday perseus can join them
hudson you're the
shakespeare of langley
and bell
arctic here
there's the head doesn't it
bell you made two extraordinary
sacrifices to stop perseus
one was without your knowledge the other
you made that decision in your own
accord
[Music]
i just want you to know this little
thing that's happened with you and me
it was always for the greater good
your goddamn hero you know that kid
heroes have to make sacrifices
that's why when i ask you for one more i
hope you understand
it was never personal
[Music]
so
you